hey guys I'm Ryan Wright Sonoma turn so
today we're checking out a trailer the
official debut trailer for Dishonored 2
aaron was coming over and he
specifically said he wanted to make sure
he got to check this out with me so
let's do it
PS um not Miller with dishonor Germany
it's a mask
it's happened again someone's pulled the
rug out from under you an empire at your
feet and you've lost it all
be honest did you really deserve any of
it more important what would you do to
get it back
careful there's always a price to pay
what you decide will ripple across the
years it'll be fine watching this on
phone oh wow what would we do with the
power of giving you how will you make
your mark on this erection
Wow okay
really ahead other time yeah it's the
dishonor series is kind of like the ball
hodgepodge of Peary's aesthetics and
technology
you cover your face I know who you are
Emily called with me please girl thing
as an accident everything is in motion
all of it has led you to this exact
second in time
oh that was convenient further uh-oh
that was painful
my girlfriend
can she teleport by shooting like a
clock manacle Adam MS actually gets her
revenge
she's a badass
thank you for you stack if you kill me
you become the especially claims you
were
what is she um so that voiceover at the
beginning wait years are long it's
always good to see
you have permission to speak okay so the
voiceover at the beginning of the game
is a guy named the outsider who's kind
of like this sort of trickster eat empty
kind of like devil figure what happens
in the first game so that mask belonged
to a guy named Corvo Corvo was the Royal
bodyguard for this Empress he ends up
getting framed for the assassination of
the empress wei empress is like female
emperor at yeah exactly
he says that's exactly right so there's
no Empire oh people worshipping a woman
I mean it's a political figure so
they're not really worshiping her
I know but listening to a woman that
happens yeah what [ __ ] my girlfriend's
right there yeah she's touching your
veneer I don't know do you know I do
with this banana earlier Oh watch the
last video to find the outsider comes to
Corvo offers him all these spooky ass
magical powers to help him get revenge
and get Emily who is of the little girl
the daughter of the Empress next in line
to ascend to the throne and also is
implied to be corvo's illegitimate
daughter gotcha now it looks like this
is taking place several years after the
original game
Corvo is somehow out of the picture
Emily's grown up Emily's grown up and
sort of taking on corvo's swashbuckling
banner is it because at the end of
Dishonored it's like Corvo either is
implicitly like a horrible role model
for Emily who's murdering people or a
good role model for Emily in that he
only murders some people and now it's
like the outsider seems to have come to
Emily and and set her on a path to do
some crazy cloak-and-dagger [ __ ] well
there you have it people I have covered
all of it
I have literally broken down this game
for you
Aaron was pointless and coming on this
video no reason to be yeah no reason to
be here yeah like I just go wherever the
wind takes and we learn to give an
opinion and some commentary with you I
sleep waste of my time and space it's
interesting to have like a female
protagonist and dishonored being because
the first game kind of
warranted some criticism for how it
handled women even though there were
well yeah he did ever you want a woman
I'm with consent yeah with with their
explicit consent I mean yeah well you're
renting out duh
no you shouldn't do that but you know
it's a video game character come on I
just kidding with your folks I just
making a funny anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out Aaron on
the real rejects dank ass Stubbs podcast
with him and Jerry check it out
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement people like
what no no I know that we're gonna do a
shout out and said oh shut up Steve me
cam gradually stumbled upon some of your
videos on YouTube and instantly
subscribed he didn't even watch them no
you're like that best friend that
everyone wants to party with or wants in
their wedding party or some [ __ ] that I
hate groups of people yeah it's like
what soon as there's more than one
person rule I'm not there yeah I'm
actually starting up a blog this summer
called campfire werewolf which will
mainly focus on 80's and 90's pop
culture and related in nostalgia and
I'll or does there's not enough of that
on there no no no and we need more
trailer reactors yeah and I'd be forever
grateful if you provided me with a shout
out my Instagram is at campfire werewolf
if you care to give it a whirl okay sure
I'm confident my blog will be a smash
hit
wow you are way too cocky for someone
starting up this he's come he's shut you
know he's kind of like the secret you
know he's gotta believe in himself
before before the law of attraction
brings good things his way is that like
a woman thought oh the secret was
written by a woman yeah yeah we have
like six more paragraphs Tommy James
shout-out request to go through so I'm
confident my blog will be a smash it
because I plan on using hidden messages
that contain satanic spells that will
make my readers and it's a mindless
zombies loyalty campfire a werewolf
that's a great great plan except for one
thing
there's
singsong bees yeah yeah satanic spells
can only be used to turn people into
other things so I'll be more than happy
to turn the favor should you ever need
it the [ __ ] would I need from you do do
you want to like could sort with a
Wiccan cuz you use your chance yeah now
that I finished worried myself for a
[ __ ] shout out I'll be alone at the
bar if you need me peace and longevity
Steve okay what bar is this Steve Steve
Steve see this is satanic bar message me
in private the bar all right
I'm gonna text you my number that's on a
separate cell phone a mine you can't
text me when it's before 10:00 cuz after
tens with my girlfriend goes to sleep
just tell me what bar you're at I'll
meet up with you okay
we just no kissing he was offering
satanic spells I don't think he's like
trying to hook up I thinking well I
think he wants to do a dance with the
devil in the pale moonlight not